hey you to Canada I'm Natasha Negev
endless and I play Carmilla in Carmilla
the movie come take a look at our set I
[Music]
was a vampire for seasons 1 2 3 of the
webseries but at the end of season 3 I
regained my humanity to heart
this is five years after the webseries
left off so we see these characters
transition from their life and college
into a more grown-up world in the film I
am I am a human again but I do start to
show signs of revamping and so the plot
sort of starts as I try to find my
humanity again at the 2017 Canadian
Screen Awards
Natasha Wanda fan Choice Award for her
role as Carmilla and says it was another
chance to showcase queer positivity an
honor and a privilege to provide more
positive onscreen representation for the
queer community from my community was
really important to me to make that
speech not only about the fans but also
what it means to the fans the webseries
has been viewed a remarkable 70 million
times and has been translated into 20
different languages worldwide the stars
of the series and film think there's a
few reasons it's been so successful
mainly the realness of the characters
and the fans including the LGBTQ
community it was broadcast on YouTube so
people who lived in countries where
being queer is illegal or outlawed or
where they would never see clear
characters on major television they had
a chance to actually watch these
characters and identify with them I
think that Carmilla is a series that is
really sincere and the relationships are
so genuine in many ways this is one of
the first shows it's really normalized
queer characters it's really special to
hear how much the show means to people
and how much they connect to it